There had not yet been a sunrise but even
then there was light you have not seen
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
lord of the rings trailer video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here there's a whole bunch
going on so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i will be doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them all it's starting september 2nd i believe
there's supposed to be eight episodes and they
might wind up dropping the first couple of
episodes on day one but the most important things
about this trailer like the most eye-catching
things are some of the first age flashbacks
or what seem like first stage flashbacks to the
war of wrath that's the war that sauron's master
morgoth fought against the combined forces of
humans elves and the valor after which they
essentially trapped him in an abyss he was too
powerful to kill but they could trap him for all
time sauron who's basically like the main villain
of the show during the second age was his disciple
during the war of wrath during the first stage
and when the war of wrath was happening sauron had
been defeated during a different battle he feared
that morgoth would punish him for his defeat he
hid for the rest of the war and then continued
to hide after the valor were punishing morgan to
avoid being judged by them as well it seems like
we get a shot of him during the trailer like i
do believe that he is going to be the person in
the meteor just because the visualization of the
meteor makes it seem kind of like a flaming eye
like the eye of sauron i think the sauron is going
to be that meteor person you also see the flames
of the meteor coming inward like magic is being
used no human would be able to withstand flames
like that so clearly it's a very powerful person
and sauron was capable of creating illusions
and changing his appearance during this period
just an early theory but you can let me know
if you think the person in the meteor really
is sauron and just to be clear the most powerful
characters that get involved in most lord of the
rings stories especially during the first stage
and the second age are the valar they're kind of
like the highest level of gods that were created
by the one true god of the tolkien lord of the
rings universe called eruluvitar he rarely gets
involved but usually when people think of him
they think about the downfall of numenor which
obviously is probably something they're going to
do in the final season of the show but it's
going to be a long time before that happens
there's a lot of numenora that we see during this
trailer too but like if you look at the chart here
under the valar or basically the mayar they're
another level of gods but they're not quite as
powerful or quite as old as the valor sauron was
one of the mayor gandalf for instance is part of
the istar wizards the wizards are also related to
the mayar so gandalf was kind of like sauron not
quite as powerful as sauron but that's why gandalf
is so powerful so basically all the wizards are
kind of like cosmic beings walking around in human
form but there are all kinds of rules about how
they can use their powers so they're not nearly
as powerful as they are in their true forms that's
why gandalf kind of seems like he comes back to
life during the lord of the rings movies later in
the timeline the big threat the great darkness
that is coming that everyone's talking about
in the trailer is obviously sauron and that's
meant to be hammered home by the meteor crashing
to earth at the end of the trailer like oh you
think darkness is coming no it's already here but
at least at the beginning of the series very few
people actually believe what galadriel is saying
about this coming threat the opening scene is a
galadriel talking about the dawning of the world
like in the beginning of the world itself and
this opening shot is of a boat entering numenor
numenor obviously famous because of the downfall
of numenor that happened after sauron was able
to trick farrah's own this character here
into invading the undying lands basically
thinking that it would give them immortality how
wrong they were what are the other cool details
about the numenoreans too and you see this in the
architecture like it's meant to look beautiful in
their capital but all this other architecture that
you see that looks like numenorean architecture is
all built by them so like for instance gondor even
though it was built by a silder and his father
technically was built by numenoreans pretty much
like all the really big really notable structures
that you see in middle earth during the lord of
the rings movies later in the timeline was also
built by numenoreans this city while she's talking
about light as the city of tyrion and these two
trees provide light to all of valinor the big
continent of the undying lands the person here
that's walking up on the hillside is galadriel's
brother finn rod the reason why this is a
flashback is because he died during the war of
wrath and morgoth destroyed the trees that's why
i think that at least during episode one we might
get some crazy epic flashback like a prologue that
we got at the beginning of fellowship of the
ring i'll talk about this later when we get to
that scene in the trailer but galadriel has this
special grudge against sauron that a lot of the
other elves don't have so i'll explain why that
is like why she wants to hunt him down so badly
this is another elven city it could be linden
because that's where gil gallard the hiking of the
elves rules from we see some scenes later there in
the trailer then there's voiceover from one of the
harfoot characters they're kind of like the show's
version of hobbits that existed earlier in the
timeline hobbits didn't come till the third age so
technically they can't do hobbits so they're doing
hard foots instead she's talking about how elves
have forced to protect dwarves have their minds as
we see cause of doom during its prime when the
dwarves were still thriving there she says men
have their grains but we harfoots have each other
we are safe just as you see the meteor crashing
across the sky like sauron crashing across the sky
but then they show you the big deal here cause of
doom during the second age you see full-on life
everywhere like it's teeming with life and very
active is an entire kingdom underground the
mightiest kingdom of the dwarves at this time
all the architecture should look familiar to
the peter jackson lord of the rings movies
the joke that gimli told about them calling into
mind was meant to be a reference to how epic
it was like they call it a mine but it's really
so much more and even though this is meant to
be underground the reason why there'd be all these
green plants growing here is probably just because
this is close to the entrance the whole reason
why kaza doom eventually fell is because they
mined too deeply and awoke the balrog who had been
hibernating and essentially it was the balrog that
was responsible for the war that killed all the
dwarves and kicked them out of the mines the one
that you see them fighting during fellowship of
the ring there's a waterfall shot with galadriel
talking to one of the other elves that were part
of the party that she's traveling with in the
north notice how different their swords are too
elven swords are a really big deal usually they
carry some kind of enchantment they're like
some of the finest blades that you can wield
also speaking of elven craftsmanship this is
keller brimbore the person who created the three
elven rings of power it'll be interesting to see
how long it takes the show to actually show the
forging of the rings like when that'll happen will
it be season one season two season three who knows
you notice galadriel's party finds this snow
troll here as they're searching for sauron
she winds up fighting it later in the trailer
and just to explain the reason why she's so
hardcore about this why she's going around to all
these different groups trying to marshall support
to find sauron is because two of her brothers
died during a battle during the war of wrath
and her other brother finrod the one that we
saw on the hillside looking at the two trees
he died in sauron's dungeons which is why she
hates sauron so much then young elrond gets into
an argument with galadriel and she says he's
not seen what she's seen and they show you her
memory of the aftermath of the war of wrath that's
what's going on in all these red scenes with all
the bodies floating this structure behind them is
basically like a tower sinking into the ocean it's
meant to show like a whole part of this landmass
like an entire city sinking into the water the war
of wrath was so devastating to the planet that it
sank a giant portion of it so i think that's the
idea of what we're seeing here like all these
dead bodies being buried underneath the ocean
this is gil gallade hiking in the elves talking
to elrond saying that darkness will march over the
face of the earth it'll be the end of everything
basically as they show you all the main races
of the show elves numenoreans harfoots and the
regular middlemen these people here are called
middlemen because they're like regular humans who
were not numenoreans and they were just already
living in middle earth this time but it sounds
like galadriel elrond and gil gallade will be
some of the only people on the show at least so
far that we know that won't be totally fooled by
sauron when he shows up like they'll be waiting
for some darkness to come this seems like an army
of orcs attacking a tower that iran deer is on
it seems like they capture him because you see
him fighting with a chain around his ankle later
like he's fighting some kind of wolf creature
this scene seems like galadriel sailing in the
swan ship with her group of elves they might be
trying to sail back to valinor and that might not
work causing the shipwreck that she gets in later
this is tar muriel who's meant to be the region
of numenor the current ruler inferazone her cousin
at this point he's kind of like her trusted
advisor obviously he winds up doing very shady
things during the course of the show that lead
to the downfall of numenor he's kind of like a
littlefinger type character trying to usurp power
from his cousin even though technically you have
to blame sauron who's the person to trick him
into invading the undying lands causing the
actual downfall itself the white petals that she's
looking at might be from the white tree the white
trees in lord of the rings like the one we see in
gondor shed their petals when they sense a threat
approaching and like the poster that they revealed
for her she's holding one of the blossoms which
it makes sense because of the meteor and sauron
coming to middle earth this great threat that they
keep talking about like the tree senses the threat
of sauron and that's why it's shedding its petals
there's another wide shot of kaza doom as elrond
goes there to convince the dwarves about sauron to
get their help again this is the scene of duron
iv smashing the boulder his father during the
third is the one wearing the crown this is
hal brand in numenor this is a rondeer like
i said his armor looks amazing obviously during
a different scene it seems like it's depicting an
end just because it's got this wooden face on
it and i believe in the last teaser they did
show some actual ends this is a big cavalry of
numenoreans led by galadriel this is a scene of
galadriel's shipwreck this is our first shot
of a silder on a numenorean ship and it seems
like he's the one that's saying that the past is
with us and then it's his father elendil saying
that the past is dead we either move forward or
we die with it this seems like a lendil riding
horses with galadriel on numenor meaning that
galadriel probably comes to numenor at some point
then this is during the fourth saying that this
could be the beginning of a new era and obviously
it's meant to be a very loaded phrase because
he's holding mithril which is a huge deal for
them incredibly valuable but i think they're
also implying what will eventually happen like
they will mine even further down wake the balrog
and that will be the end of kaza doom basically
this could be a flashback to the first age
actually showing the sons of feyenoord vowing to
pursue the semirolls the oath happened after the
two trees that we saw earlier have been destroyed
by morgoth so they were vowing to go rescue the
simrolls at all costs and then just based on the
way that they framed this meteor scene with all
the fire in the shape of the eye forming here it
just seems that they really want you to think that
this is sauron he could be using his magic to make
it seem like he's crashing to earth or he could
actually just be using his power to straight up
crash to earth but remember after the war of wrath
he went into hiding so it seems like he's trying
to use this way to come back and pretending to
be an emissary from the other valor like i'm
coming from the gods to give you all these gifts
to help you when really is going to try and trick
them to create the rings of power the whole idea
in creating the rings is that was meant to be his
backup plan to take over the planet after morgoth
had been defeated so this is like the beginning of
him putting his plan into action but everyone
post all your theories in the comments below
if there's anything big during the trailer that
i didn't talk about or any easter eggs that you
spotted that you have questions about just write
them below in the comments like i said it's gonna
be a while before episodes start but there'll
be a couple other trailers that they'll release
there'll be a lot of fantasy stuff happening this
fall between this and the house of the dragon
episodes that i'll be doing videos for but they're
going to be on completely different days so don't
worry about that comic con is happening next week
there's going to be a bunch of trailers like every
single day so make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that i'll try to do
videos for as many things as possible everyone
click here for my brand new mandalorian season
3 trailer breakdown and click here for my brand
new loki season 2 first look video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!